thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show common sense for
your dollars and cents
darro is with us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Dora how are you I did thank you very
much I'm doing great I'm very grateful
to be getting on the show I am a victim
of identity theft by like forty or fifty
thousand and I'm a school teacher so I
filed for bankruptcy back in October and
now I'm I filed for bankruptcy and why
did you file for bankruptcy because I
didn't know anything else to do I went
to the police I went I I was just super
overwhelmed and I've been dealing with
identity theft for two to three years
and it just seemed like a dead end that
no one knows what to do when I when I
went to the police they're like you need
to bring this document oh you need to
bring this document you need to bring
this document it was so long the
identity theft my father actually used
my credit cards my social security
number when I was in college
and when I was living outside the home
and he would actually get credit cards
taken out under my name unbeknownst to
me because I wasn't living at home at
the time and I was working and going to
school and stuff like that and it's a
special kind of scum that does that to
their own kid no doubt no doubt
especially being a school teacher so I
just always paycheck to paycheck and
stuff like that and gosh I wish I'd
gotten a hold of you because you don't
know any money you weren't bankrupt you
just had a problem yeah so now you filed
bankruptcy back last year right correct
okay so where are you today how can I
help so I am too when I was filing for
bankruptcy they said oh you don't need
to pay Center in the bankruptcy courts
you don't need to pay your car payments
while you're in the bankruptcy court
you're protected that's what the car
company said and that's also what the
bankruptcy lawyer told me said okay I
want to retain my car so I'm in a lease
right now which eventually I want to own
one day my little junker car and but
right now I'm in a lease and I'm two
payments behind on the phone bill behind
I'm a car insurance behind I'm like one
month behind like almost all essential
utilities and stuff like that
we're on why are you behind because I
had to pay those two car payments like
right away
because the bankruptcy lawyer did you
follow did you file a chapter 7 correct
okay yeah he and why you're not supposed
to pay the payments while you're in
there but you needed to have saved them
up and you didn't I did not because you
know they were just yeah they said it
was going to be put on the back end of
my lease and I said okay that's fine
I'll just stand the lease and so it's
miscommunication on the car company and
then I was using that money to say
you're out of the bankruptcy all the
identity theft is behind you because of
the bankruptcy and the car is current
and you're one month behind on some
other stuff I'm two car payments behind
June and so I don't own the teacher so
I'm paycheck to paycheck start how far
behind were you just two car payments
almost three where I was gonna get
repo'd but then I took I send in my
phone bill I extended my car insurance
each five months and now I'm playing
catch-up constantly I just don't know
where to start
I'm confused I thought you got behind
because you caught the car up no okay
what money go where the money go that
you were making when you weren't paying
car payments it went to regular daily
living of I'm only there's never it's
only like an extra 300 is your car
payment 320 and what is your household
income about twenty five hundred a month
okay how much is your rent eight forty
how much is left on this car leash
probably about a year 2019 okay good
what we need to do is we need to
prioritize our very very carefully what
you're gonna pay and what you're not
gonna pay okay
all right starts with food you're gonna
buy food and it's not eating out it's
eating at home beans and rice rice and
beans okay then the second thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna get current on
the utilities okay before you do
anything else
utilities are not cable TV utilities are
water and
ass and electricity that's all I have
now
okay good are you current on those I'm
one month behind in the utilities I'm
always getting like a $10 late fee SS
okay you're so you're gonna buy food how
this mix check you're gonna get current
on your utilities okay then you're gonna
pay your rent
okay yes then we're gonna work on the
car payment and the car gasoline and
anybody else you do anything else after
the bankruptcy just about 250 each month
I pay to felt friends and relatives 250
in total each month
it's a cellphone and relatives no to
family and friends 250 each month I got
on a $25 a month payment plan people
that loaned you money that repay $5 yes
do you owe them 500 each okay good okay
okay so if we take 2,500 right - a 300 I
love car payment - an 800 dollar rent -
food - lights and water
I've still got money okay you following
me yeah car insurance is 100 okay that's
down the list okay right you're gonna
eat first we're gonna get current on the
lights and look we got to catch this we
got our state keep the rent current so
food shelter clothing transportation and
utilities before you do anything else
like sixth grade civics class in the old
days yes I will miss all daisy-chain yes
I am a teacher and so the basic stuff
right okay and a written game plan that
you stick to because what's happening to
you is you've gotten into a tailspin and
you're like dizzy-bat you know you ever
play that where you put your head down
on a bat and spin around and youth group
or something until you fall over because
you're dizzy that's exactly what you're
doing because what happens is you you
run over to one thing and you stop on it
and then you run over the other
thing you step on it and then you run
over to another thing you step on it and
nothing ever seems to get done because
it's just all stress-related
and impulse and emotion driven decision
making okay and so the things that are
very very important don't get done the
things that are squeaky do get done and
and he feels very very very out of
control to you and listening to you you
sound out of control does that make
sense yeah so I want you to get like
real methodical and cold-hearted about
this and walk through taking care of
Dara food food lights and water rent get
the car current call the friends and say
not this month I'll start again next
month I got to get my car current you
know if something doesn't get paid
that's not a necessity we'll get back
around to it okay but we're gonna you
know you've got the money to get around
to it but what's happening is is that
you just you had three or four things
hit you at once and it's put you into
this cycle and it's a stress
decision-making cycle and it's it's it's
killing you it's killing you emotionally
it's draining you emotionally but it's
also got your finances completely out of
control too so if you lay out a plan and
just not give a rip about who's pissed
but you take care of Dara first you can
work your way through this the math
you're giving me is not impossible okay
you didn't call me up with $5,000 a
month in bills and $2,500 income you
call me up with $2,000 a month in bills
and $2,500 income but you're behind the
eight ball and you got to get back in
front of it Saul you can do this this is
very very doable and keep talking to the
car company as a matter of fact call
them once a week and just pester the
crap out of them up and remind them
about how they screwed this up totally
totally yeah just just just even if you
can't send them money send them hate
yeah okay you know just mess with them a
little bit because you know eventually
you might actually get us a supervisor
on the phone in collections who does
roll that payment onto the back and that
would help a bunch
that was okay what you know if you don't
you can still turn this and then the
other thing is I want you to start doing
some tutoring okay and pick oh yeah I
work I work on the weekends I do dog
sitting babysitting and I also do okay
and I want you in Financial Peace
University our year-long subscription
and it comes with a class and a kit and
I'm gonna pay for it I want you to go to
the class it's all free from me because
I've been scared like you're scared you
can turn this around if you need more
help you call me this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Music]